i was just like really clear it was just
a really clear night and like the stars
was out and i just remember
like looking out up at the stars and i
just remember just like asking myself
like
i just remember asking myself who was i
becoming
all right andrea yes andrea where did
you grow up where are you from
originally
i am from cleveland heights ohio
and tell me about your family growing up
you had both your mom and dad um no so i
my mom raised me i lived in a
single-parent household um
my dad was never really around he was
never really a part of my life
um he kind of let me know like around
the time my mom died that he
divorced her because she wouldn't abort
me
so my dad never really wanted me so i
just grew up with my mom
wow your mom did a good job thank you
thank you
i think i think she i i i think she did
but i mean
i don't know i'm into so much
you know that
i think she would be a little
disappointed but at the end of the day
it's my life so i can
i should live my life the way i want to
live my life
you went to school
yes i went to high school and i
graduated from college with an
associate's degree in arts good for you
thank you but you chose another career
at least temporarily right yeah
i um
so
i started dancing when i was 19. i
started exotic dancing when i was 19.
and
um i got off into like doing some
escorting and like being a call girl for
a short time um between the ages of 19
and 22. that opportunity is presented to
girls that work in the clubs right yeah
yeah um
so
i actually started dancing because um
my dog got really sick
and um i was kind of cut off financially
from my mom for
like ever since i was maybe like 15 or
16
and so i just didn't really have much
financial support
and um she started kind of dating
someone and
um i kind of felt like she wanted me to
move out and like have my own place and
stuff i just wasn't ready i've never
seen my mom date anyone before so
i feel like she kind of slightly just
acted a little differently i could just
tell it was time for me to get my own
space and stuff so
um i just needed the money and i started
dancing when i was 19. um
i
my mom introduced me to one of her
ma best friend's
sons who's a writer in the music
industry
and at the time
i was 19 and he was like maybe like 40
and he kind of like propositioned me in
a sexual way he asked me to like
perform oral sex on him for 80 bucks and
i was not very comfortable i just kind
of felt like
i didn't have to do it in what context
at the club no this is this is before i
was dancing so this is what kind of made
me start dancing
um
he said he would give me money to help
my dog but he wanted me to like he was
already like kind of like
grooming me in a sexual way um so
because he wrote music
i at the time i wanted to be a singer
i've always wanted to be like a singer
and like be in theater and do plays and
stuff and um
i feel like to some extent he kind of
prayed on that and um
he wanted me to like record this demo
song for him to send to like um a singer
in the music industry
so like my mom wanted me to do it and
like it just seemed like a really great
opportunity because i used to sing um
growing up like i've sung at like the
house of blues in cleveland and
one contest at the radio station and um
so i was open to
to singing the demo
and so
the only thing was is i could only do it
like after like after like school and
stuff like that after work or whatever
and so i would have to sneak out like i
just kind of would sneak out of my
bedroom window and
go to his house so i can record
um you know recording in his studio his
in-home studio
he didn't live that far either so i mean
it was kind of like it was cool like i
didn't feel like it was any way to get
caught like it was like foolproof
and um
so
um
he kind of was like i guess his fiancee
had just recently passed away so
he kind of was like coming on to me like
in a sexual way and i kind of figured
like
well i was flattered at first because he
was like so much older than me i was
like really flattered but
i mean i didn't really
know like you know i didn't really know
i was getting into or whatever
so this particular time i needed the
money and
my mom
she obviously was dating someone and she
didn't want to like you know help me out
financially anymore my dad was never
really around
so um i got into this really big blowout
with my mom and i just told her
you know
i need if i can't have it if i can like
i need some money like i need help i was
working like two two jobs at the time
and i was paying my own car insurance or
whatever i mean i was like really young
i was working at amber crumby and fitch
and um uh and i was working at like
valley title fitness or something
and i just needed i was like broke and i
just was broke
i was just broke and so um
i just told my mom well okay that's fine
you don't have to give me money i'll
just start getting it from men in the
street
and obviously i don't think she believed
me
i i didn't believe me but i was serious
about it i needed to i needed money
and my dog was sick
and anyone who knows me knows i love my
dogs
and so i
i told this guy that i needed some money
to help my dog and um
and he told me that he would give me the
money if i performed oral sex on him
and at first i was like i was like i
mean i was i just didn't know how to
feel about it um
just so happened that
i had a
nurse who would come and help my
grandmother that was living in our home
i guess she used to like turn tricks
like back in the day and um
and i kind of told her i'm like i kind
of was going to her for advice i'm like
hey this guy he said he's going to give
me some money
but he wants me to like
give him like head or whatever and um
she was like
well if you're going to do it this is
how you do it so i mean i didn't expect
her to say i didn't know what she was
gonna say but i just needed like i was
talking to an adult about it and i
wasn't gonna talk to my mom about it
because it was like a secret
and um
she just kind of gave me some rules to
it and
one thing she made very important to me
was safe sex and protection
and so
i mean i had every intent on doing it
but
i got uncomfortable because he didn't
want me to use a protection like he
didn't want me to use a condom so i got
super uncomfortable with that and
i just felt like there's no way i'm
gonna put my
beautiful lips in jeopardy by
performing oral sex from this guy on
this random guy
i just rather go to the strip club and
i don't know take my top off and guys
will pay me for the fantasy of being
with me instead of having sex with them
so i was dancing um
i first well i don't want to say the
clubs i worked at but i first started
out um
dancing like this it wasn't necessarily
a hole in the wall but it was just like
a real like
laid-back quiet place or whatever
and my first audition
song i danced to was britney spears
circus and um
and they hired me
of course i was underage but they hired
me so that was my first dancing job
how long did you do that
so i worked there um for maybe like a
year
and i always like there's like three
major clubs in cleveland that you want
to work and i wanted to get to like the
big dog club like we're all like the big
huge mansion looking like
look like um
playboy mansion i wanted to work there
but i just
i don't think i had the experience at
the time so i started out as like the
smaller club and
i did that for about a year i um
but what would happen is that i would
start to develop feelings for my
regulars that would come in and see me
so i would start to like like them and
have crutches on them and stuff
and um
so like
that's unusual yeah i know most of these
girls despise their their clients yeah
no i i i felt like i feel like they
cared about me to some extent
and i cared about them to some extent
too so
i just felt like it was a working
relationship and
i had really like
developed feelings for this one client
and um
we ended up like hooking up
and um
i went to talk to one of my friends
about it that worked in the club with me
and i told her oh my god i said i hooked
up with this guy i hooked up such and
such and she was like oh really and i
was like yeah and she was like well did
he pay you for it and i was like
no
i mean was he supposed to
and she was like yes you never like you
never do that and not get paid for it so
i was like oh okay so
that's when i started to like
make money from it but
i mean it wasn't like i was just kind of
like a streetwalker it was more so like
i was really developing feelings and
like
i don't want to say falling in love with
them but
i really cared about them and
you know
i feel like
i feel like they cared about me and i
feel like they did care about me so we
just kind of like would hook up every
once in a while like
every two weeks like they would fly into
town like on business trips and stuff
and um
you know it was really nice for me as a
younger woman like i would be in these
really huge expensive hotels and like
they were so nice like they were so big
and they were so pretty and um i don't
know i just feel like a little princess
because they would spoil me and they
would let me order a room service and
like get cakes and like um
i don't know everything i wanted and i
just can help you with your financial
security yeah
so i had the best of else like i was
pampered and i could just you know make
my own money and i never had to ask
my mom or my dad for anything else i
need i never needed to ask anyone else
for money because i was
technically working for the money but it
was like a some type of leisure to it so
it was cool
and your heart was even involved yeah so
it didn't it didn't feel so bad like it
didn't really feel bad i mean i've had
like
bad experiences like um
like some guys would like
like some guys i would feel like will be
like murderers and stuff so like um
this one guy
i was sitting on his lap just talking to
him at the club and um
he was just kind of like
you should get away from me and i was
like
why like i was like you know having fun
hanging out with them like why he's like
because i break women
and i was like what do you mean and he
was like i take them to my basement and
i break them and you're way too pretty
for for me to do to you what i normally
do to them
and i was like
okay well thanks and i loved
and then um
so but so you run into a lot of
situations where guys will um
like are into like some like abusive
stuff like you know they may be into
watching like abusive porn and stuff
like that so you'll have like
moments where you may be doing a
champagne room and normally the security
is supposed to be like
watching on the cameras to make sure the
girl is okay but i've had instances
where guys
will like put me like in a headlock or
something or be like hitting me and like
like
like like beating on me and
i mean
i didn't really have anyone come in and
help me so i just kind of like had to
like
wait until it was kind of over
and just try to stay on the other side
of the room and keep a distance between
us but
most of the times in that environment
guys are like high on coke and like it's
just a lot of coke and a lot of drugs
circulated and i never tried any drugs
other than like marijuana
but um
yeah you'll have like you'll meet guys
who are really like
into some weird stuff like i was
actually um
dating this one guy
well i actually dated two guys that i
think murdered their girlfriends that i
kind of like met in that industry
just from like partying and stuff like i
would run into them and like they they
were just always in the area um at the
club that i worked at
so
this guy was dating
um
well
he liked me he wanted to date me but i
just wasn't sure if i wanted to date him
yet and i just was talking to one of my
friends about it and they were like you
know he murdered his girlfriend
yeah i'm pretty i think he murdered his
girlfriend but like he was trying to get
me by myself and
i was like against it obviously because
like i think he murdered his girlfriend
and like you know i've just met guys who
just like who are just into some dark
stuff and like we'll make certain jokes
about like
killing their girlfriend and putting
them in the cuyahoga river and it was
really
nerve-wrecking for me because people was
really being found in the river like
dead like women were really dying
and like being found in the river so i
just been in some like close call
situations where it could have been
really bad for me
but i was able to like get out of that
situation thankfully because i didn't
know what was gonna happen like this guy
was dating and i went over to his house
i thought it was just going to be him
but it ended up being like
three of his friends and i just kind of
came in and i just didn't know what i
was walking into
and so i was trying to be normal like
not feel like like not let them know i
was scared or anything and like
i kind of like asked a question like um
so yeah so
why are you single and he was just like
because i killed my girlfriend and threw
her body in the river
and i was just kind of like okay
well
i'm gonna get ready to go
so i left but
you'll find a lot of that in the strip
clubs like you'll find like a lot of
like
politicians and like police officers at
the strip club too like
a nice portion of my clients were police
officers and this one police officer
like
i guess you you start to feel
uncomfortable because some people have
so much power that if they did something
to you they can get away with it so it's
just a really scary situation to be in
because
you never really know like
what could happen to you and if you ever
be found like um
there was one police officer that was
like really really obsessed with me in a
way but he was like a regular he would
come to the club and you know i would
dance for him or whatever we never
hooked up or anything because i was like
really scared of him
but
um so he wanted my phone number and um
i gave him
my number
and well actually no
i just told him i was going to give it
to him at the end of the night and so um
at the end of the night the security
usually comes out and like clears out
the premises so no girl feels like
afraid
and so
and so i got in my car
and i started and i seen him like i see
him in his car but i was hoping like if
i started just driving off he would
never like
like like of course you don't think
anyone's gonna chase you down the street
in your car
and it was like really late like four
o'clock in the morning and um
he started following me and he was like
chasing me
and i was like trying to drive and
trying to get out the way because i
couldn't believe this officer was
chasing me he's a police officer and i'm
like
what the [ __ ] like if it's a police
officer chasing me like what the [ __ ]
like
so then i got to a red light like the
right the light turned red and so i
stopped at the red light and like
he hopped out the car and he started
knocking on my window and he was like
you said you were going to give me your
phone number
and i was like okay well so i gave him
my phone number
and he called it right in front of me
and i was so happy i gave him my real
number because i felt like
if i were to give him a fake number
like
he probably would have been pissed so i
didn't really know what to do so i just
kind of gave him my number but
you'll just find like
guys who like have their like they have
like really
sick obsessions with girls like they
will become like really obsessed you'll
get stalkers and stuff like that like
like this one guy um i met um he kind of
became a stalker and i don't know if he
ever like had my home address or not but
um
one day he texts me and he he was like
um
i bet you're wearing
like he said something about the color
of my underwear
and
the color of my underwear was exactly
what he said it was so like i don't know
if he was like following me or not so
you meet some weirdos
yeah it was crazy
yeah it was really scary and i was so
young like i didn't really know what to
do like i never told anyone
i just kind of was like well that comes
with the territory you know like you're
playing with guys desires and sexual
urges so
you never know like
how they may respond especially
depending on the type of like
porn and stuff that they're watching
like people
start to like dehumanize you in a
certain type of way where you're more of
like just a sexual object so you you
never really know
how people would respond to you like um
but then like that's when i started to
kind of like realize that the fetish
industry was really a lucrative industry
because i would have some clients come
and just want to like um buy my
underwear that i was wearing they wanted
my used underwear so they would like buy
their my underwear and just smell my
underwear
and um
i had some guys come and like
just want to like smell my feet and like
lick my feet and stuff and
that was so funny so that's my first
time i ever like had like uh i ever knew
that feet was like a thing that people
like get into so
i would start letting them like kind of
like suck my feet and smell my feet like
so that was kind of fun so yeah and it's
safer as well i think right yeah and you
don't have to have sex
so i liked it that because i didn't want
to like
i got uncomfortable at you know at a
point in time i kind of felt like
i felt like maybe the money was changing
me and changing like
my outlook on life because everything
became about the money and not about
like
who i was as a person and i didn't
really like how it was making me feel
and how it was making me
feel about myself like um
one night in particular i was leaving
the club and like
obviously these were still guys that i
was interested in like like uh
physically attracted to because i would
only like go towards guys that i was
physically attracted to because it would
make my job a lot easier like i wouldn't
have to like
like deal with any guy that was like
stinky or musty or anything like it
would be guys that were like clean cut
attractive like
i mean they weren't always fit but i'm a
chubby chaser so i like heavier guys so
um
but yeah so one night in particular
i um had like
like two clients like i had like two
clients like lined up that wanted to
like sleep with me for money
and
i just remember like
and this and this was two guys and like
in like
the same day and i just remember like
before i went
um
and these are two like separate
things i've never like done any like
gang bangs or trains or anything like
that but it was just like i've never
slept with
more than one person in a day and i
remember like
walking outside of the club and like i
don't know this the sky was just like
really clear it was just a really clear
night and like the stars was out and i
just remember
like looking at up at the stars and i
just remember just like asking myself
like
i just remember asking myself who was i
becoming
and um
thank you
i just remember like looking up and just
asking myself who was that becoming
because i didn't know who i was anymore
so i didn't end up going through with it
i didn't end up seeing either one of
them but
it just bothered me that i felt
comfortable like
maybe like sleeping with two guys in the
same day for money and i just it
bothered me that i felt
okay doing that and i didn't do it but
um
obviously like well well well in my
childhood i grew up like in a very
religious environment i was like raised
in a strict religious environment and um
so i knew right from wrong
but of course right and wrong is
subjective
depending on the person you ask
so um
i it just didn't feel right for me
um
and even being religious like i felt
like i was never really understood in my
religion
because of my own like
childhood traumas that i never really
addressed or never really um
really felt like
was something that i needed to
acknowledge
um
like i was molested by a lot of of my
babysitters
relatives and family that i would be
left with when my mom was at work
and um
i think it first started happening
before i was even in school like before
i was in kindergarten
i started being molested and
most of the people that was molesting me
were women
so
that caused me to like struggle with my
sexuality really really hard and at some
point in time like it
i just was introduced to sex at a very
early age so
since i was introduced to it at an early
age like as i became
in my teens and like my my pre-teen
years i
um kind of like developed like a porn
addiction
and um
i just was like really entrenched in the
world of sexuality and exploring
and like exploring your sexuality
so um
i mean i kind of felt like
i didn't know if i was like gay or
straight but i knew i had developed a
strong attraction to women
and
um yeah
at first
i first was molested when i was like a
kid and it happened when i was playing
hide and seek and i was hiding in a
closet
and this particular person came into the
closet and started touching me in my
private area and my first instinct was
to get up and leave
but
this person told me that if i got up to
leave that the boogeyman was going to
come get me so that's how young i was i
was afraid of the boogeyman
and i never told anybody and i never
said anything
and it just started to happen on a
recurring basis at different people's
houses and um
i don't know it just wasn't a good it
just didn't make me i don't know i don't
know i don't know how i felt but it's
just things that i would never forget
um like one experience i had where
this um
ozer guy
molested me at a babysitter's house and
he
he had some like mental
i don't know what was wrong with him but
he was like a violent
he was a violent person so
um
when he would touch me i would want to
like start like screaming or asking for
help and
he would start like hitting me
and um
like like hitting on me and i was like
scared to say anything so i never said
anything i just kind of like took it all
in and i just was like well this is some
weird this is some weird [ __ ] that's
going on maybe it's just like
i don't know i just thought like maybe i
didn't think it was normal but i didn't
know
why
i was like the
target in in in every different
situation it just seemed like no matter
where i was like if i was at school or
if i was like at like at
i don't know like i don't know like just
like babysitter's house or just like
wherever you know it would just kind of
happen so
i just thought like maybe like
i don't know i just didn't know what to
think about it
um
yeah and then i would start to like so
this so the guy that used to like
molest me and would start hitting me if
i was telling anyone
um
so he had sisters that were um there as
well
and um
one time i was just venting to them
about being afraid of the dark and he
was like well she was like well you know
my brother really likes you a lot so if
you if you're ever afraid you know you
can always call him for help and he
would do anything for you so that's when
i started to equate
um
love and abuse together synonymously so
i was like okay well maybe people will
develop like these strong feelings for
you that they can't control their self
so they'll
beat you up
or hit you
and so i was just like
i kind of was a little flattered
yeah
humans are interesting
yeah
so the fetish thing you're doing now
are you more at peace with that are you
more comfortable with that so yeah i'm
more at peace with that because i feel
like i don't have to like have sex with
anyone
so
so how i started doing that is um
so obviously some things happen at the
strip club
with my feet and i was like oh this is
nice i can't make money doing this
so um
i stopped dancing when i was like 22
um because i like got really entrenched
in a particular christian sect of
religion and i got baptized and um
i just kind of was like like a lot i
kind of like this one story where this
guy
um i guess was dating this girl
and
asked her to like like text her and ask
her to see pictures of her feet or
something and
um
she kind of betrayed him and like was
telling her friends about it and putting
in a group chat and stuff and making fun
of him and
it had gotten back to me
and at the time i was the new cute girl
around i was like you know the hot girl
the new face or whatever and everyone
was making fun of him
and so
um
i reached out to him
and i let him know that there's nothing
wrong with
him liking you know feet there's nothing
wrong with
embracing your own kinks and your own
sexuality there's nothing wrong with
that
so we end up like linking up
and um
he would like you know like click my
feet and stuff and like i just let him
know like you know you're free to do
whatever you want with my feet like you
can be comfortable being yourself so i
felt good because i felt like
i was doing a service to humanity by
letting him know it's okay to be himself
and he can consult my feet whenever he
wants to and um
so that's where it started
and then i noticed that
um
i don't know just like guys who i just
were here like
we're having like a hard time like they
may be nerds or something and people
were just like making fun of them for
liking feet like i just would let them
know that it's okay to like feet and you
can suck my feet and look at my toes and
stuff and um
is it less violating for you
yeah i think it's like i kind of like i
i kind of like noticed that i liked the
dominating
another
male
is how i felt like dominating a male
made me feel good so you're more in
charge yeah
yeah so they would stuck my feet and i
could just do whatever i want like i
could just you know
i could do whatever i want and it made
me feel
it made me feel like empowered like it
made me feel like i had control or power
over i imagine the money might be better
too right yeah they were paying me well
at the time they weren't paying me at
the time i was just doing it for fun
but um
one day i had um
painting my toenails this really pretty
like dark red color and i posted it on
instagram i was like new nail polish
and like i got all these messages from
these guys like oh my god your feet are
so pretty can i worship your feet and i
was like i didn't know what that i
didn't know what that meant but i it
never occurred to me that all this time
i had been letting people worship my
feet all this time
so
i started like looking more into it like
looking at the foot fetish community and
stuff and then i started using hashtags
so people can discover my feet and so i
made up only fans for my feet and then i
would have guys reach out to me
and pay me for pictures of my feet
and um
like sometimes they would want videos of
my feet too so
you know they would just you know i give
them some photos and some videos of my
feet like doing some weird stuff like in
mashed potatoes or spaghetti or
something like that and sometimes they
would want me to change my nail polish
so i would charge some extra for that
and sometimes they will want me to make
like um
like a a gift list on amazon
and um so they can buy me like jewels
for my feed and like accessories and
stuff
and
so then i was started to make a lot of
money from it um
and then i would start to charge my
friends
to
like suck my toes and lick my feet so
now i was making a lot of money doing it
because a lot of guys
that i had grown up with
and had no idea that they had this
fetish a lot of them started to reach
out to me
and it was cool because i was
comfortable with them because i had
known them for so long
so
it was like
sometimes i would like you know they
would i would link up with them and they
would just like you know lick my feet
and stuff and
i sent pictures of my feed and videos
and i started to make a lot of money
doing it and um
like the fetish community in general is
just a really good lucrative business
because you'll have guys who want to
like
buy your urine and
and stuff like that and then you'll have
guys who like
like like currently i also dance too so
like you'll have guys that are into like
some other kinky stuff like
like they want me to slap them or spit
in their mouth and um
i mean
it's it was fun for me
because i was able to you enjoy the
control yeah and now i can
inflict abuse on someone else
consensually
with no one being hurt
on purpose
yeah so it was cool what have you
learned about men
from all of this what if i learned from
what about men oh what if i learned from
men about men do you see men differently
because of this
um
i don't
i don't know i don't really see men
differently because i feel like maybe i
never really
knew what men were about anyways because
you're not really judging them yeah i'm
just kind of like letting them be
themselves
and um i don't really know what it will
look like to like i don't know like the
whole concept of a real man and a real
woman like i don't even know like what
that even means so it's just like
i just feel like everyone should be free
to be themselves and do what they want
to do and
if it's consensual and it's and it's you
know
and no one's being hurt
um i just feel like everyone should be
free to explore their own sexuality and
embrace their sexuality and
during this time i felt like
it gave me an opportunity to embrace my
sexuality as a woman and not feel like
people were taking it for me
so um
like i've been raped a couple of times
like through the process of dancing and
stuff like that and meeting people that
you think you can trust and
you find out that they're maybe you were
too trusting so
um
i just kind of feel like it's a way for
me to take back
my sexuality where i'm saying like
this is my terms this is on my terms and
this is all my conditions
and it's no longer being like stolen
from me
it's no longer feeling like something
precious is being ripped away from me
i feel like i just have more control
over it i feel like i can do what i want
and i can ask for what i want
and it makes me feel empowered like i
feel like in society today like we try
to like
like
condemn sex workers and people in the
fetish industry and i just kind of feel
like depending on the person that's
doing it like if it's consensual and if
that's something they want to do
that's for them like i don't feel like
it's okay to condemn people and make
them feel like crap because of what they
choose to do like we all have our own
kinks and we all have our own fetishes
and we all have things that make us you
know
that make us tick and no one should be
like shamed because of it and i'm just
all about embracing yourself and
embracing your sexuality
that's great
yeah thank you and a little bit safer
for you right
yeah it's a lot safer because it's on my
terms
though i feel more comfortable saying no
because i can say no
i can say no no i don't have to do
something that i don't want to do
and
i don't have to like
feel uncomfortable or feel
like i don't do anything i'm not
comfortable with
so
you know it's it's less about
that person on the receiving end and
more about my comfortability and i can
you know i can say no when i want to
like i don't have to do anything i don't
want to do
yeah and so most times it's not like i'm
like soliciting myself myself or
anything but most of the time the guys
will get like so excited that they'll
just like climax in their pants
so i don't really perform any acts or
anything or touch them in a sexual way
they just like
you know get excited and you know it
happens in their pants like i'm fully
clothed they're fully closed and they
just kind of like
you know get off on just feet and so
like they'll be so embarrassed and and
stuff like that but you know i laugh
it's a little it's a little funny to me
it's flattering
but um
so but you know it's it's okay though
it's okay you know everything's gonna be
okay all right we'll all be okay yeah
yeah because
a person embracing themselves is the
best thing
in life you know being happy with
themselves and being
happy with who we are you know
like i kind of feel like
sometimes we get so wrapped up and
everything else like
like personally for me like
being raised a very religious person
i just never belonged in my religion
because i was just so
different like because of my
life experiences as a child being
molested
i
was drawn to
certain sexual things like so
i just didn't feel like i belonged
because either the like the people were
like
really like picking on me or just making
me feel like i felt out of place and
some of the people wanted me to fill out
the place
like i felt like i
like i just felt like they didn't want
me to feel comfortable and so
i didn't feel comfortable and
i just never felt like i could be
successful
in that particular
um
religion because i just felt like i
couldn't that i wanted i wasn't i was
always in trouble i was always in
trouble because
i was just me and
i guess i'm in trouble but um
like i've been
disassociated
a couple times
i'm currently disassociated now
and basically that's when
no one's allowed to talk to you or you
know
anyone if you have family that's in that
religion they're not allowed to talk to
you
no one
affiliated with that organization is
allowed to converse with you so
you feel outcasted and you just feel
like you're thrown away and
like you're disposable and like people
will forget about you
for
making mistakes or you know
struggling with in a certain area
struggling in a certain area people will
just make you know
make your issues their issues
by
um
by just showing you that they can no
longer like
be associated with you and it it's more
hurtful than anything
for me personally because
i've never really had like i've never
really felt like i've had like
much of the ideal family situation
anyways like not having a father and
having older sisters that i kind of felt
like didn't really
take on to me because my mom had me when
she was so much older
it was kind of like
we were in a separate
generation so i never really developed
like a sisterly bond with my older
sisters and
like
i don't know i just like after the death
of my mom like things got really weird
and um
just got really weird and uncomfortable
and then i end up getting like
disassociated from my religion and
and they like i just feel like they i
don't know
just used it
like one of my sisters i felt used it as
an excuse to like not talk to me and not
converse with me
yeah i just i've just always felt like i
never really belonged anywhere like i
was like severely bullied throughout
school
um like i didn't even like i wasn't i
never even went to preschool because i
was bullied in preschool
and then i was homeschooled in sixth
grade in middle school
so then i was like integrated back into
public school and i was raised in a
diverse area so like when i first
started school all of my friends
were like
white
hispanic you know black and then like
i'm like so i just got thrusted into
public school with like
majority black um students and that was
an uncomfortable experience for me
because obviously i stood out
and i was like really bullied about the
way i talk the way i dressed and
um i don't know it was hell it was
[ __ ] hell i got my ass bullied like i
used to be crying in the bathroom like
that's how bad it was like i would be
crying you're a good student though i
was yeah i was a good student i was just
kind of like i was just a quiet girl i
was like a really quiet shy girl like no
one really knew me i was like elaine
that's what i was called a lame
so no one should ever feel that yeah no
one should ever feel that way
but um
you know
i
i feel bad because i feel like
i would come home and like bully my
brothers and it made me feel bad because
i felt like i was making them feel like
the way
people in school was making me feel
and i still regret that even still and
i've since then apologized to my brother
because i wasn't happy for the way that
i acted
thank you
i wasn't happy for the way that i acted
but i feel like you know
it's weird
like be like the whole bullying thing is
very weird anyway it's always hurt
people that hurt people yeah and so i
wasn't proud of how i handled being
bullied because i would come and bully
my brothers live in the household so
that made me feel like a shitty sister
so um and then my youngest brother
passed away he was like um he was
murdered in 2011.
and that kind of like during that time i
had already started dancing
and so
that just became like a whirlwind of
emotions because i started to like
use sex as a way to like
mask my pain and not deal or process
with the things that i was going through
emotionally so i would kind of use sex
as a tool
and um i think that's what my biggest
problem is is like learning how to like
process
my emotions without feeling like i need
to like um
have sex with someone
and and
most times it's not very enjoy sex is
not really an enjoyable thing like for
me growing up like having sex like when
i first lost my virginity i thought it
felt like death
and
like i didn't start having sex again so
i was like 18. i lost my my virginity
when i was 16. oh my 16th birthday
and it was so bad
but um
yeah i don't know the guy i lost my
virginity too he was like a sweetheart
he would like
come to my bedroom window when he got
into fights with his family and just
come and spend time with me kind of was
like a safe haven for him he would like
bring me flowers to my bedroom window
and stuff so just kind of happened but
sex was never really enjoyable for me
um i just i don't know why i was doing
it i just was trying to mask how i was
feeling and i guess i always felt like
like people were always pushing their
sexual desires on me and like doing
things to me
as a kid
that i just kind of was like well maybe
this is what
like you're supposed to do i don't know
you know
so i think that's kind of like where
my struggle is is trying to identify and
figure out why
sex became like a tool to feel better
even if it wasn't enjoyable i think
maybe it was the intimacy i was like
looking for like being intimate with
someone and getting a hug or just being
embraced it just kind of made me feel
better and i was willing to do whatever
to like fill that void and just kind of
like
obviously it backfired and my life was
like just spiraling out of control and
um
yeah i don't know
just kind of felt like i didn't really
belong anywhere
i didn't i don't know the places i
thought i was supposed to be
like in my religion the places i thought
i was supposed to be i just didn't fit
in i was never gonna be perfect enough
sometimes that can be frustrating just
not being perfect enough
and um
one particular time
one of like the highest ranking
men
in the
like
in the organization
the church yeah like he would like like
he like will obviously go around from
district to district or circuit or
whatever
and um
he came on to me in a sexual way
and um
i didn't really know how to take that
um i felt like i lost faith in religion
after that to be honest like i just was
like
i don't feel safe anywhere when it comes
to people and like their sexual desires
and um
like no one like
no one in my congregation ever like
voluntarily came to me to let me know
that wasn't my fault
and so
i don't know
i just didn't feel as safe
and i just didn't feel like um
i don't know i just didn't feel like i
belonged i just feel like anywhere i go
people were going to be sexual
you know towards me or just towards
anyone like people
you know anyone can feel
like uncomfortable
and um
yeah i
after that happened like after i
experienced him coming on to me like
that
and no one ever coming to like really
like coming to me like voluntarily
coming to me and saying that this wasn't
your fault
and that you didn't do anything wrong it
just bothered me because i felt like
when i am doing something wrong everyone
is quick to correct me or like make me
feel like
like i just wasn't good enough and like
i was like breaking everyone's heart and
like um
like breaking god's heart
and um
but i just felt like when someone
wronged me like like when a man of a
certain status
wronged me no one really it didn't seem
like they cared i mean just in some way
they cared like no one i just didn't
feel that embracing that love to let me
know that it wasn't my fault and that
bothered me
that bothered me a lot because i was
told that this was a place that i
belonged and ever since i
came into it i just never felt like i
belonged i just feel like the odd girl
out and
i think because of my past a lot of
people held that against me and just
never really wanted to give me a chance
and um
i feel like if i would have spoken out
against this man like
my past would have been brought up and
i was just kind of like over it like i
was just over it at that point in time
and it just really bothered me mentally
it just bothered me mentally for a while
and
i don't know i just
it just bothered me so i just kind of
like strayed away from
organized religion
because
sometimes you're just really not safe
anywhere
so yeah i don't know
andrea well thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck with whatever you do
thank you i appreciate that thank you
you